hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website calm excited about the
start of the 2014 World Chess
Championships and knowing that we're not
going to have another championship for
two more years the stakes have never
been higher to competitors the reigning
champion Magnus Carlsen the young gun
the Norwegian his opponent Vishy Anand
from India he played last year as the
champion this year because he won the
candidates tournament earlier in the
year he is the Challenger but he wants
the crown back so definitely excited for
those curious this goes from November
8th through November 25th there's a day
before and day after that as far as the
opening ceremony and a closing ceremony
but each player they'll have two games
so they play one game a day and then
they have a rest day and then they play
two more games and then there's a rest
day and they also alternates colors in
this first game we're going to be over
today Vichy and Nas going to be playing
the white pieces and Magnus Carlsen is
going to be playing the black pieces so
hopefully you guys are sad as I am we'll
go ahead and get started with game
number one going into the first match I
was definitely interested to see how
both sides would come out of the gates
last year if you remember the first four
games they played were all drawls and we
were just kind of waiting for something
exciting to happen so hoping that kind
of Vichy and Nan gets us off to a great
start with the white pieces and then
obviously Magnus Carlsen the best player
in the world right now playing the black
pieces excited to see how he defends so
Vichy starts out with pawn to d4 one of
the most common openings from
grandmasters nowaday
and then we see Knight f6 a pawn to c4
and pawn to g6 so playing the grünfeld
defense something that we don't normally
see Magnus Carlsen play so maybe he's
been studying some different lines that
maybe he wants to try out a gallant
vision on maybe there's some tournaments
lately he's seen from Vichy that he
thinks this is a good offense but
definitely something that we're not
super familiar with from Magnus Carlsen
playing on a regular basis Knight to a
c3 pawn to d5 so if you're not super
familiar with the Grunfeld defense
there's a few variations that you can
play the most common line that you'll
see is the exchange variation and that
is the exchange variation that we see
in this particular game pawn taking here
on d5 we do the exchange off the board
right here
Bishop to d2 and this is kind of a
subtle change in how white approaches
the Grunfeld defense black does have a
few options as well he could after the
bishop comes here to g7 Fein Cato and
getting ready to castle on the King side
he can take here on c6 he can later push
forward with a pawn to c5 he could play
Knight to c6 so he has a lot of
different options he doesn't again have
to take this he can always kick back
here to b6 and then try to push forward
a little bit if he wants to so he does
have some options after pawn here to e4
magnus carlsen decides to go ahead and
play the exchange here on c3 and the
reason this bishop came here to d2 is
the subtlety of Bishop taking here on c3
and not having to worry about this pawn
here on c3 now again the Grenfell
defense is a hyper modern defense so
black is not trying to control the sort
of the board right here instead he's
trying to develop his minor pieces
towards the each side so this bishop is
being cut out it's controlling the
center from the side of the board the
knight could come here to c6 you can
always play pawn to b6 if you wanted to
being hit as bishop here but later going
to be looking forward to push forward
with his pawns he could push forward
with pawn to e5 and try to break up the
center of the board again pawn to c5 is
definitely something that we see a lot
of times in the grünfeld defense so you
know black definitely is not trying to
do anything right now but later on
Magnus Carlsen has a lot of different
ways that he can counter play Magnus
Carlsen now castles on the King side and
then Queen to d2 and again anytime
you're going to be developing your minor
pieces typically that's going to be
where you castle so why it's going to be
looking to castle on the Queen side then
possibly control this semi-open sea-fowl
right here up magnus carlsen then played
at Knight to c6 and he had a few options
now again because it is a hyper modern
defense he's trying to control the stern
of the board so a knight to c6 starts to
have a lot of pressure on this pawn here
on d4 he has both his queen his knights
and his bishop right here but
a lot of times you'll see the bishop
come outside here and then maybe pawn to
e6 once the bishops outside then let's
say Knight to d7 and then pawn to c5 now
protected by that Knight right there so
96 although it is fairly straightforward
it's not always the most common move in
the grünfeld offense but from here we
see Knight to f3 and again vision on
could have decided to go ahead and play
pawn to d5 trying to alleviate some of
that pressure on his pawn on d4 but you
know Knight to e5 that's going to be
fine right here for black so instead
just decide to play the more common move
Knight to f3 Bishop to g4 trying to get
the light to grow Bishop out involved
into the game sometimes depending on
what the pawn structure might look like
with you know pawn here to e6 this light
square bishop just kind of hangs out
doesn't do too much so definitely get
involved is going to be good for Magnus
Carlsen
now the pawn pushes forward with pawn to
a d5 and then we see an exchange here so
it's pretty interesting how both sides
want to play this Magnus Carlsen could
decide just to go ahead and play his
knight somewhere else but decides you
know what I'm not too worried about it
right now I'm going to go ahead and
exchange off this Viator bishop that I
don't want to be using on board Vichy
and on the sides okay I want to get a
little aggressive as well I'm going to
go ahead and exchange both these dark
square bishop Soph the board so after
the King takes we're now going to see
the pawn take here on f3 and then after
the knight comes here to e5 we see a
bishi and on castle on the Queen side so
again very interesting to see how both
sides wanted to exchange in that
particular case you know with just right
here this Knight is attacking the pawn
on f3
you know vichy wanted to castle anyway
but it would been extremely bad if he
just lets magnus carlsen take right
there after here it's going to be a huge
mistake if magnus carlsen takes just if
you haven't seen it
Queen to c3 check and also attacking
this knight it's going to be very very
bad for Magnus Carlsen so we can't do
that instead of needs to come up with
another solution and so he decides to go
and start chipping away at the center of
the board
he recognizes he
pretty much completed his development
does need to get his queen involved but
he needs to start breaking up the stern
of the board so we can have some sort of
counter play so let's look at what both
sides are trying to do here for blacks
perspective he's looking to exchange
here take here on d5 bring his rook over
here to c8 really control this long
vowel right here
a white definitely needs to have some
sort of safety with his King so if he
wants to bring his King over here to be
one that's going to be okay
you know White has a few options he
could play pawn here to f4 kind of
forced this knight to move back here
could always play Bishop to h3 not
allowing his opponent to bring his rook
over here to c8 any time so white could
also if you wanted to start to try to
attack on the King side so pushing
forward with pawn to h4 at some point
getting the LightSquared Bishop maybe
over here starting to add more pressure
on the King side bring his rook over
here to g1 and really start to attack
his opponent this is also very
opportunistic for anon it really depends
on how aggressive both of these players
want to be typically if you have both
sides cancelling on either side of the
board there's going to be fireworks but
again first game you have a 12 game
series in this whole match it's going to
be interesting to see how aggressive or
Hort how passive both of these players
want to play so first we're going to
have Queen here to c3 this kind of
forces Magnus crossings hand he can't
move this Knight it's pinned down to the
King right here so he really only has
this pawn to f6 now this does mean
Magnus Carlsen even more so wants to
play his rook over here to c8 because
then if he could ever just play you know
pawn to d5 all of a sudden this Queen
it's kind of in a tough spot because
it's being pinned down to the King right
here so vision ins decides he wants to
go ahead and play Bishop here to h3
stopping the potential threat of rook
over here to c8 he again I think would
have been fun if he played the pawn here
to f4 kind of forcing this now
to move back here to let's say f7 and
then after the the pawn takes right here
you can see Queen to c7 you know the
pond can't really take here on b7 would
be giving up material and board you
could have the Queen come down here to
f4 check if the Queen or if this King
comes over here to b1 then you know
check and then this pond is going to
fall if for some reason the Queen comes
here to e3 then you could have Queen to
c7 check and then you could just gobble
up this material here on b7 so it would
have been interesting to see how that
would have gone f4 would have been a
pretty fun and aggressive move but
Bishop to h3 again talking about the
threats that Magnus Carlsen has makes a
lot of sense from vision on so we're
going to see this pawn take here on d5
the pawn recaptures here on a d5 always
important to know the different pawns
that may have some weaknesses on board
this pawn right here on d5 is an
isolated Ponce who doesn't have any
protection from the other pawns black
definitely can put a lot of pressure on
this pawn now it doesn't have a lot of
bishops or some of his other minor
pieces beyond this Knight
so it could be tough to put too much
pressure but he can start to build up a
lot on this semi-open d-file black on
the other hand has the backward pawn
here on e7 so that's something to to
keep in mind if an on wants to go ahead
and put a lot of pressure on this
semi-open efile he can start to do that
and then Vichy and on also has the
double pawn here on the F file
definitely not something you want to
have going into the in game something
that magnus carlsen and may use to his
advantage so we now see the knight come
back here to f7 opening up the
possibility if he wants to play Knight
to d6 kind of stopping that again
there's not another pawn that can kind
of force this night away and since he
does have this upon protection right
here it's kind of an outpost even though
it's kind of high up the pitch here on
d6 still a nice little outpost for black
pawn here to f4 just starting to try to
put pressure on the King side again if
he wants to he can go ahead and bring
you
over here to g1 and really start to add
pressure on the kingside of magnus
carlsen now Queen to a d6 of threatening
this pawn right here
Queen here to d4 just centralizing the
Queen also adding a protector to that
pawn right here rook over here to d8 so
kind of what we talked about starting to
add pressure on this pawn here on d5 and
they're really great move by Vichy and
on we see Bishop here to e6 a nice
little outpost for this Bishop right
here it's going to be very difficult for
Magnus Carlsen to deal too much with
that Queen over here to b6 and Magnus
Carlsen decides hey he's completely okay
to exchange off these Queens on board
potentially he doesn't like the
situation on board too just wants to
exchange everything off and go ahead and
kind of to a draw-game bishi and on is
not happening has the white pieces he
came for the championship he wants to go
and try to fight for the win as much as
possible but you know he could have he
could have taken right here we see an
exchange on board all of a sudden Magnus
Carlsen has double pawns here on the B
file which is not where you want to
double pawns you could now see the king
come over here to be one Knight to d6
and it could have continued from there
but as we talked about on game we see
the Queen come back here to d2 still
protecting this pawn on f4 so always
important to make sure he's putting his
pieces in position to defend all of his
pieces so rook over here to d6 opening
up the door for another rook to come
over here to d8
add more pressure now rook over here to
e 1 and now we start to see potentially
pressure on this backward pawns here on
e7 so if we see something take right
here then all of a sudden block is going
to have to worry about this pawn here on
e7 we do see the knight come back here
to d8 attacking this Bishop pawn here to
f5 and then we see just an exchange off
board and now White has to decide how he
wants to take one option would be to
take with his rook he could also take
with his pawn so a few options on board
probably the best choice is what he did
and that's taking with his rook here on
e6
now Magnus Carlsen has a few options he
can
just forget about it and not worry about
taking this material right now he could
play Queen to c7 that's an option
maintain pressure not only on this rook
on d6 but also on this backward pawn
here on e7 which is now under attack he
could also just take with his rook right
here
and then we see the pawn take here on e6
and then I'll say Queen to c5 again
still holding down the pressure on here
check King over here to be 1 and then
rook swinging over here to c8 putting a
lot of pressure in the game with those
kind of two options at hand Magnus
Carlsen decided to go for the Queen to
c7 again this is checked still kind of
defending both of his squares we see
King come back here to be one nice safe
square for vision on so to be curious to
see how he continues with pressure
recover here to c8 controlling this long
see file right here rook over here to e1
now adding more pressure on this
backward pawn on e7 so now black is I
wants a force to take in exchange but
definitely much better for him so now
the rook ticking here on e6 to continue
to add pressure to this pawn on e7 rook
over here to d8 now adding pressure on
this pawn right here and so we see Queen
to e3 now adding pressure to the pawn
here on e7 rook to d7 and then the palm
pushing forward recognizing that if this
rook were to swing down here or even
this Queen then this pawn right here on
e7 would be undefended by less than two
pieces so that would be not great so the
pawn takes here on d6 instead of taking
back right away decides to go ahead and
first just to prove this position a
little bit Queen taking or Queen to d4
threatening this Queen to f7 so black
has two pieces defending this square
here on d6 but now machine ons kind of
forged Magnus Carlson's hand to defend
this square here on f6 so we see the
rook swing over here
and now after the pawns take right here
we do see the rook take here on d6 so as
we get into the
in game here both sides have two pawns
on board neither side has double pawns
so boasts both pawns structures are
going to be fine
both sides have equal material both
sides have fairly somewhat safe Kings
you can't really get your Kings too
involved into the game usually in the
endgame you want to get your King
centralized you can't really do that
when your opponents have Queens on board
because they can just do some scary
stuff and they can really threaten all
your other pieces and pawns on the board
so you're going to see the King stay
pretty safe and then just see if either
side the board can find some small error
or advantage in the endgame so I'm going
to see pawn to a6 pawn to a three Queens
a five pushing forward with have for now
the Queen's going to come back over here
to h5 threatening this pawn over here
the Queen just comes back here to d2
both sides just kind of moving around a
little bit just threatening as much as
they can but again there's there's not
much both sides can do right now the
King coming back here to a2 just trying
to stay as safe as possible
rook to e7 as you can see they're always
having both the rooks and their Queens
kind of partnering with each other
whether they be on the same column or
file both of them are pretty much doing
the same thing throughout so Queen
coming back here pawn to e5 to Magnus
Carlsen starting to try to push on the
Queen side now the Queen's again come
over here to f1 starting to threaten
some of the push that may happen from
black here pawn to a4 how that works can
swing down kind of partner up with this
Queen right here Queen to c2 and then
the rook here we now see the rook come
back down here attacking this pawn on h2
also White was kind of threatening the
Queen to a b5 here adding two attackers
on the pawn here on a4 and it'd be very
difficult for black to kind of swing
over here into finet so rip to e2 kind
of stops all that and it also adds an
attacker here on the pawn here on h2 so
now we see a rook over here too
b4 and then pawn to b5 and white can't
take this so it may look well okay this
is undefended and he brought his rook
over here to attack this but he can't
take Queen here to c4 that would be very
very bad that would be pretty much just
game over White's going to lose his rook
so don't want to do that instead on the
game I decided to go and bring his rook
over here to h1 and then we see the rook
swing back here to East 7 again both
sides just can't find any errors on
board and so eventually after the King
comes to h6 then we see some repeating
moves and then eventually both sides to
go ahead and shake hands and draw the
first game after 48 move so I kind of
expect it it's the first game in a long
series usually not going to see too many
fireworks so vision on played pretty
standard d4 opening Magnus Carlsen
decided for a very sound and structural
you know nothing too crazy with the
Grunfeld defense he didn't try to get
out any crazy lines so kind of what I
expected was hoping for a little more
fireworks I'm hoping that tomorrow when
magnus carlsen the defending champion
comes out with white did he play
something a little bit more aggressive
maybe it won't be for like I'd hope for
but I'm definitely hoping for something
pretty good both sides though again I
think are highly motivated to win this
again since they'll be champion for two
years so excited for this series
hopefully you guys enjoyed watching the
recap of this game maybe you learn
something that'd be cool too I'll see
you guys in the next video thanks for
watching